i'm a big fan of matthew vaughn i would
imagine both of you are as well uh for
fans of his what do you think might
actually surprise them to learn about
matthew and the way he works on set
well the one thing i sort of took noted
and took away from it was that
despite having these huge sequences and
huge sets and
the the the
the pure massive people involved in in
some of these
scenes
he's he's he
he's very calm and he's amazing at
orchestrating him but he also is very
open to
to change and collaboration to a certain
degree you know i think that's something
that um
i didn't necessarily expect on a
film like this
yeah i agree i was so um
i was so surprised by that how he is so
collaborative and
i guess because you think someone that
has such a strong identity in cinema
would be sort of like this is how it
goes but he's not and um
and i think he was also you know really
he really loved working with us the
actors and um was very sort of
he would sort of give it over to us
actually sometimes especially in the
kind of more serious scenes you just
sort of say you do it you go for it and
and trusted in us and
um i i thought that was really
surprising as well and i thought he was
so good to work with and
and had such great insights and um
uh yeah and obviously he's this
incredible visionary uh director who
completely sees it you know you're
making the film and he's like well now
i'm going to cut to this and he's got it
in his mind totally which was great
because i had no idea what was going on
half the time so
okay
you
know uh the other thing about matthew is
that he he creates with obviously his
crew uh these really cool action set
pieces in all of these kingsman movies
um what was it like actually to be a
part of those things because i can't
imagine these are easy to film
you know what's evident is that matthew
and this isn't taking away from what
matthew does but he he surrounds himself
with incredible people you know brad
allen and the whole stunt team
are so dedicated to getting every
element right and it and
you
despite being in films and you know
having done fight sequences and a few
little stunts here and there and other
stuff
you you still sort of um
not overlook but you forget how much
goes into it and i think this was like
you know i started physically like six
months before
shooting and and and and you can see why
because it is um
it is so well
planned and and the camera department
are tied into it as well from very early
on and
you just feel
[Music]
very
safe and very like comfortable in their
hands and and for me i was just like i
was just
i felt honored to like be a student of
these experts and and be open you know
gemma and i had the same um
trainer tony bayless who was like
ex-military ex-paratroopers special
forces like one of the best kind of
person we could have had to like give us
that military
um weapon weapon work background i think
like you know there's not many other
jobs where you you get to go to work
every day and and um
and get to crawl around in fields you
know there were some days where i was
just like you know crawling around
random fields in the english countryside
with with tony and you sort of go home
and you're like yeah this is this is
cool you know
well um maybe
switching to something else i really dig
how this film incorporates real history
into the telling of this story um can
both of you talk a little bit about your
reaction to reading the script for the
first time and seeing the way he was
twisting it all together
yeah i mean it was i remember when i
read the script i was like whoa this is
full you know like there's a lot going
on
and
world war one like the build-up to world
war one in itself is a really weird and
million loads of different things going
on lots of
different elements as to why it got to
the point
of war and um
and that
that and then the family stuff um with
the oxfords and then the kind of
formation of the kingsman
it was just like wow i mean i thought
how is he gonna do this i wasn't you
know it felt very very dense
but when i saw the film i thought he'd
done an amazing job at getting all of
that in there but making it
making it understandable and palatable
and also
making you still care for the characters
because sometimes with films with so
much event in them
you don't care for the characters
because there's not enough time to kind
of invest in them and i think you really
really do in this so i really
you know top my hat to matty vaughan
because it's not an easy job and he did
a brilliant job in my in my opinion yeah
i think
agreeing with gemma totally that
the amount of stuff i didn't realize um
actually happened you know despite
matthew
um sort of changing and taking us
more like
um
maybe sort of mad take on certain
elements of history a lot of that a lot
of in the film um i was surprised to
learn was actually
um stuff that happened so i think for me
that was the
biggest thing coming out of it yeah
uh obviously i'm sure
what everyone who sees this movie is
going to be blown away by recess
rasputin i mean he is giving it i hate
like 10 percent in every scene and i'm
just curious for both of you what was it
like watching the finished film and
seeing what reese had done because it's
so good
it's so good i mean
i have been a fan of reese's fans for a
long time and he's so like in my opinion
a bit of an underrated actor and to see
him like
transform and do this really disturbing
yet
very very funny performance i mean he
really
is like incredible what he does
so yeah i just i can't wait for people
to to see that because it's so memorable
and it's so unique
yeah yeah
i mean also reese is like the most
charming charm he's like the most
charming
funny like normal
guy ever so like when he stepped on to
set as rasputin it really was like gemma
said a massive
like transformation physically like
vocally he used to do this
crazy like vocal fray in the morning and
like changed the pitch of his voice and
the tone and
um
i i also had a lot of scenes where i was
like certain comedic moments that i
couldn't really
hold it down for that was quite tough
you know like sitting opposite him and
also sometimes when you're doing scenes
with someone and like you just catch
these incredible moments you really just
want to like you just want to smile
because of how good it is and you just
um you just sort of marvel at
what's happening but yeah i think people
everyone's mentioning that fight scene
everyone's really
enjoying what rhys has done and
rightfully so because he's incredible
uh harris this is for you the no man's
land sequence that you were running
through was like real explosions going
on so is it safe to say that your
reaction in the film is like real life
like oh this is this is deadly
yeah yeah i wish i wish i could sit here
and say i you know i acted my socks off
but i really um
i really was more just thinking about
like hitting the mark and not breaking
my legs and not getting hit in the face
there was one you know there was one
scene where they said they they the
pyrotechnics guys came over and was like
you know if you run too close to this it
will you'll get hit with shrapnel and i
was like is that i mean is that safe
like am i i mean am i allowed to do that
or
um so yeah i really was just thinking
about not um not dying so
yeah whatever you see is that really
just pure fear
well i think a lot of people think that
uh making movies is just very glamorous
all the time and i i
i think both of you can attest that it
is a very physical and taxing gig
making the movie of this size and scale
yeah absolutely i think everybody got
injured at some point um apart from me
and um
yeah there were a lot of kind of sore
knees and backs and arms and
every
everyone and most of the time you're
cold you're so freezing there's you know
it's it's one thing i mean obviously not
complaining because we are so lucky to
do the job that we do it's the best job
in the world and very lucky to do it but
you are often very cold and in you know
you've got to look like you're kind of
warm and you're freezing freezing
freezing freezing that was probably my
experience just being very cold
yeah
heard i've heard that from a
number of uh actors on many things i
gotta go i'm just gonna say congrats on
movie you guys again did such a great
job good luck with the rest of your
speed dating
thanks very much thanks